[Music]
it's the early 14th century and northern
Italy is in a continuous state of
battles Wars and feuds that have
persisted for several centuries now the
source of most of this discord is
divided between the two Italian factions
each supporting rival political claims
by the Holy Roman Empire and the Pope
the cities that supported the Pope are
called glyphs or the church party and
the cities that supported the Holy Roman
Empire are called Ghibellines or the
Imperial party if you want to find out
more about the complicated political
relationship between these two factions
watch my Empire versus the papacy video
during this politically divided time the
bordering cities of Bologna and Medina
which were natural rivals at the best of
times found themselves at opposing sides
with Bologna being a starched church
party supporter and Madonna a starch
imperial party supporter this meant that
the already existing bad blood between
the cities got drastically multiplied by
the outside influences of the Pope and
the Holy Roman Emperor due to all this
the lens of Modena and Bologna became a
constant bickering battleground of
opposing ideologies for example in 1249
after the battle of for salta in which
both Madonna and Boleyn have
participated supporting their respective
factions the victorious Bolognese
thought it would be funny to launch a
live donkey over the walls of Modena and
so they did humiliating the modernise
continuing from there in 1296 Bologna I
managed to capture a few border towns
from Modena and the Pope quickly
acknowledged a new Holdings as core
Bolognese territory
but this wasn't just a one-sided
conflict for example the leader of a
starch Pro Empire leaning Mantua
Pasadena bonaccorsi
also managed to become the leader of
Modena in 1308 he was known as a loyal
agent to the Emperor Louis the fourth
himself and actively waged war against
the cities of Parma and our hero both
members of the church faction he also
led a bunch of retaliation rates into
Bolognese territory these militant
actions along with his loyalty to the
Emperor got pastarino excommunicated by
the Pope who promised to grant
indulgences be fit of a crusader if they
harm passerine o or his possessions
continuing on from there not much change
for most of the early 14th century with
and Bologna being continuously at each
other's throats until 1325 when the feud
escalated into an all-out war it started
off in July of that year with Bolognese
troops entering modernise territory and
laying waste to border towns and fields
in retaliation pastarino used amount to
an army and entered bonus territory
besieging the fortified stronghold of
Montevideo what the Vecchio was a very
important ball in his fortress because
it along with the pallino protected the
city from any direct sieges this was due
to the fact that if any army decided to
besiege Bologna they would be vulnerable
to a rear attack directed from these two
fortresses unfortunately for pasterino
this also meant that Montevideo was a
very well fortified stronghold due to
its strategic importance however an
interesting thing occurred when
pastarino besieged the fortress it
turned out that the ruler of Montevideo
was a secret supporter of the Imperial
party and switched his allegiance when
pastarino arrived
whether pass arena knew about this or
not is unknown but now with Montevideo
in the hands of the imperial party the
pallino was the last remaining fortress
on the road to Bologna and with that the
die was cast for the next stage
Pasadena didn't push deeper into
Bolognese territory because a he didn't
have enough soldiers and B he
technically wasn't at war with Bologna
yet
now it is at this point that most
English sources including Wikipedia and
military history now I'm using planet
Logan productions zephyrus X Choir real
life lore and many more will tell you
about the amusing way the war started
the story goes that during this
tumultuous time some modernise soldiers
managed to sneak into the center of
Bologna here they found a well with the
bucket switch depending on what source
he believed was either a simple empty
bucket or was filled with loot from the
most recent balinese raid and put on
display in the center of town the
modern-day soldiers naturally decided to
steal this bucket either as a symbol to
humilate the balinese or due to the
possible loot that was stored in the
bucket when the Bolognese found out
about this they were humiliated and
angry and asked the modernise to return
the buckets when Madonna refused to
return the buckets vana declared war now
this would be a very entertaining and
funny story if it were true sadly it
isn't the best way I can put it is that
the idea of a modern soldier being able
to get into the center of bologna during
this time whether trying to infiltrate
or not is just as ridiculous as the idea
of bologna having a bucket full of loot
on display in the center of the city the
story of a stolen bucket being catalyst
for a declaration of war was most likely
a misinterpretation of a 17th century
poem about the war this combined with
the fact that modern age soldiers did
steal a bucket during this war but that
definitely happened at the end of the
war not at the start so the actual
reason for the declaration of war by
Polonia was a combination of many things
including internal politics to taking of
the montevecchia bypass arena the
overarching Empire vs. the papacy
factions and the fact that belonging and
knew they were able to raise more men if
they declared war right now that Madonna
was and so Bologna declared war Bologna
was able to muster up around twenty to
thirty thousand infantry and 2,000 to
2,500 cavalry Knights well then I on the
other hand had to ask for help from
other pro Imperial cities since they
didn't have a big army
Damona needs were able to muster up
around five to eight thousand infantry
and roughly the same amount of cavalry
nights as bologna however even though
the Bolognese had a much larger force
the composition of these two armies was
quite different the Bolognese infantry
although much larger was a
equipped and experienced and overall had
low morale as a large portion of the
soldiers were forced into service the
modernise infantry on the other hand was
largely composed of trained retinue of
the various noblemen from the
aforementioned cities they were highly
skilled experienced and well equipped
when it comes to the cavalry Knights
both sides were roughly on the same
footing with experienced equipment and
training the first move of the war was
by the Bolognese whom divided their army
into two one part of the army was said
to besiege Montevideo and the second
part was ordered to prevent the
modernise army from crossing the panara
River at first the strategy seemed to
have proved effective as the modernise
army was struggling to get around the
balinese defenses however one night they
devised a plan they faked an attack on
the bridge down the stream which forced
the ball needs to redirect more troops
from the mountains right after this the
modernise under the cover of night
quickly moved most of their army
upstream leaving only small
contingencies of soldiers on the bank of
the river then early dawn on november
15th the modernise army appeared at the
bank of the Panaro River near Morano
surprising the ill-prepared balinese
defenders that did not expect to find
most of the modernist army this far up
in the mountains the Bolognese defensive
river line quickly shattered and with
the momentum on their side the modernise
pushed all the way to serve Valley where
they lit signal fires to let the
remaining soldiers guarding the
riverbank no the main army successfully
crossed the river once regrouped the
modern II started to march towards the
second most important balinese
fortresses appellee no Bologna couldn't
afford to lose a Foligno especially with
montevecchia and modernise hands and so
they lifted the siege of Montevideo and
ordered the entire army to regroup at
zeppeli know with this order the site of
the deciding battle was set at the end
of the Castella at the plateau by the
foothill of the Zap elena fortress by
the time both armies could see each
other it was already late in the day and
there is no doubts that the soldiers on
both sides were quite tired usually at
this point in most medieval wars the
leaders would signal to build a camp and
wait till the next day to engage in a
battle however modern ease leaders were
convinced the only way to defeat the
superior Bolognese
numbers was to deal a quick surprising
and a decisive blow early in the war
this combined with the modern ease
momentum throughout a day and the fact
that the Balinese army was not yet fully
organized as more soldiers were still
coming in and on Madonna had to fight
here and now if they ever hope to win at
least that's how they saw it this
resulted in the fact that the battle
itself started around 3:30 to 4:00 p.m.
giving only around 2 hours of useable
daylight after which if the modernise
didn't score a decisive victory they
would have to do a long retreat as they
were deep in Balinese territory
nonetheless this was a gamble they were
willing to make and so with the Sun
behind them they lined up on the plateau
with cavalry behind infantry and started
to march to the beat of the drums
cowards too hastily deployed Balinese
line as the Setting Sun glimmered off of
the armor of the Balinese infantry which
was a mass of up to 30,000 men packed
tightly between the mountains and the
volkl stream it became clear that even
though they had the higher ground and
superior numbers they wouldn't be able
to use that effectively in such a tight
spot suddenly the drums stopped and the
modernise infantry along with the
cavalry charged straight into the
Balinese line
however what the Balinese didn't notice
was that part of the cavalry diverged
from the main group crossing the stream
and going around a small nearby hill
after which when they crossed a stream
again they suddenly emerged on the rear
side of the Balinese army the Balinese
were caught by surprise and even though
they tried to use their cavalry to stop
the rear attack it was too late
seeing the enemy cavalry on their rear
many Balinese soldiers thought they got
fully encircled and started to retreat
from the battle breaking the lines and
creating a full panic amongst the rest
of the troops however trapped in a
valley with the only escape route now
being blocked by the enemy cavalry and
then most of the soldiers had to try
climbing up the hill to the Zeppelin a
fortress 2,000 of them didn't make it
with about 500 more dying during the
battle itself the modern ease on the
other hand suffered only around 500
casualties the battle lasted less than
two hours and Medina had its decisive
victory with the remaining Boney's
infantry scattering around the
countryside and the cavalry being chased
back all the way to Bologna
after this victory the following day
Madonna besieged and destroyed several
fortifications plus the locks on the
Rena river when the army finally reached
the walls of Bologna they made camp but
did an attempt to siege the city instead
they basically threw a three-day long
celebration party and forced the
Balinese to watch after the three days
and with I imagine a terrible hangover
the modernise withdrew back to their
city but not before some of the soldiers
decided it would be funny to steal a
bucket from a well outside of the city
walls why did they do this well you see
it was symbolic the modernise were
skilled in making artesian wells which
were wells that used the physics of
water to basically work as a
quote-unquote fountain meaning you don't
need a bucket to get the water out while
unease however didn't know how to make
these artesian wells and so they had
traditional wells with buckets so the
modern-day soldiers stealing the bucket
we're basically saying huh look at those
dumb Bolognese they can't even get some
water without the bucket according to
tradition the symbolic bucket was kept
at the monetise Cathedral after which in
modern times it was replaced by replicas
and ordinal was transferred to the City
Hall now it is debated whether even this
original bucket in the City Hall is
truly the bucket from 1325 or just a
very old symbolic replica as far as I
know there has been no carbon dating
done on the bucket but at the same time
there hasn't been any reliable source
that would cast suspicion on the
originality of the bucket so far now
it's probably safe to say that the
bucket at the City Hall is original
after these events not much more happen
in the war and a few months later in
1326 a peace treaty was signed this
peace treaty basically stated that
bologna will pay heavy war reparations
to Madonna if Madonna returned to
conquered territory and so the war ended
as it started with the status quo
unchanged
if you want to know more about the
Battle of the pallino and the war of the
bucket and can read Italian
I highly recommend the book the Battle
of the pallino and the kidnap bucket
sadly it's only in Italian but it is
most likely the best source on the
subject out there for those who don't
follow me on Twitter I sadly had to skip
the April video as I was too busy but
now we should be back on track with one
video a month as always and not to spoil
anything but the June and July videos
are going to be big ones so stick around
for history
[Music]